hi I'm Ryan and I'm Melissa and you're
prepared great so we're gonna watch the
trailer for a movie that I don't
remember the name to right now oh I just
remembered it's called bad words
it's a Jason Bateman film that's all I
know I heard you directed it too yeah
really yeah that's cool all right that's
cool
yeah she's Italian very Italian she's
very Italian hmm I'm half Italian which
makes sense why we're so attracted to
each other can't you see it like we
could possibly be related but it's kind
of hot still yeah all right like a
cousin or something yeah like a distant
cousin so it'd be okay like The
Godfather three it would be awesome sure
yeah wouldn't be awesome it's not
preferable would you hate me forever if
I said I did Racine the Godfather I told
you there are a lot of things that I've
seen and a lot of things that I've seen
clips of and hey that's one of the ones
on my list who are you what's the
trailer now sign-ups cousin Brad it's a
red band trailer but it's not supposed
to be red it's red and what are you
spell spelling me oh that's why it's
called bad words so I like to cheat
no way I can't wait it looks like he has
a cool style that is directing I feel
like this is gonna be great that sounds
like me say it to everyone maybe not it
looks awesome
lobster so dark comedy on the on the
balls do you see that I did and you
didn't get the reference no I didn't oh
did you say he's my lobster we missed
the end of the trailer because of you
and who friends references gonna be
awesome just like the first like half of
that trailer I was like I'm sold I'm
gonna watch it [ __ ] that looks great
that looks amazing I thought I'd hear
more like swearing and stuff I know
right honestly I didn't know or expect
anything yeah like I it doesn't give you
a whole lot to work off them for the
title but got to say that looks kind of
awesome yeah Jason Damon directing
awesome yeah I think he's the only
people that can turn a spelling bee into
something awesome doesn't matter what
she says she's hot okay I just think
they could have had more customers yeah
I get it though because maybe they do I
mean we only saw one how many seconds
out of the movie that is much longer
than that and quit early they probably
have like um I don't know cuz getting in
square where it's gonna be like cheap
jokes you know like when you over you
say like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] bastard hell damn it what are
you what are you doing are you seducing
me cuz it's working I didn't even
realize or see when it said it was
coming soon don't worry about it now
it'll be here soon sure oh geez yeah